[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليله واحد يا غابه الهلال معايده مغيب
الشمس ليله الاثنين يا غاب الهلال بين
مغيب الشمس ومغيب الشفق الاحمر ليله
الثلاثاء يغاب الهلال مع مغيب الشفق
الاحمر وقت العشاء وفي منتصف الشهر يشرق
البدر مع مغيب الشمس وعن طريق قمه الابداع
يعرف العامه تمام الشهري من نقصانه فاذا
كانت قمه التبدر يوم 14 قال العامه ترى
الشهر 29 يوما واذا كانت القمه يوم 15 قال
العامه ترى الشهر 30 يوما فالشهور الهجريه
شهور كونيه وليست اصطلاحيه كحال الشهور
الميلاديه فهي تعتمد على ظاهره كونيه
مشاهده بالعين المجرده فبدايتها ونهايتها
تعتمد على رؤيه الهلال ومنازل القمر يعرف
العامه اليوم من الشهر رايت الهلال ووجه
الحبيب ف هلالين عند النظر فلم ادري من
حيرتي منهما هلال الدجى من هلال البشر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والقمر يشاهد بالعين المجرده 28 يوما
ولهذا منازل القمر 28 منزله والمنازل هي
المحطات التي يستريح بها القمر في كل ليله
اثناء رحلته الشهريه حول الارض فاذا كان
شهر هافي 29 يوما فانه يستر ان يختفي ليله
واحده واذا كان شهر وافي 30 يوما فانه
يستر
لليتين وقال اصيحاب الفرار او الردى
فقلتهما امراني احلاهما مر سيذكروني قومي
اذا جد جدهم وفي الليله الظلماء
يفتقد البدر
[موسيقى]